[Applause]
all right I'm really quickly just um a
full-circle moment here when I first
started out as a filmmaker I was
discouraged at first because I'm a man
of faith and I didn't know that it was
possible to be confident about your
faith and exist in Hollywood my mom gave
me a book called produced by faith by
Devon Franklin and it encouraged me so
it's a full circle moment to be here
today to be presented with this award
so I thank God who has always guided my
steps and lit my path I'd like to thank
my wife who's here crying we've been
through a lot together we've been
together since we were 16 years old and
we have two beautiful sons and she's
always supporting me with whatever I
wanted to do and I couldn't have done
this without her I like to thank the
Academy for supporting shortened student
films as a filmmaker trying to navigate
the Hollywood system and ultimately make
future films for a living support
through programs like the Student
Academy Awards is helpful because it
demystifies the process this week has
been really amazing it's been amazing to
get to know some of the best filmmakers
in the world and watch their amazing
films for me film has always been about
community it's been about finding a
story in your community with the help of
your community telling that story and
using that story to build an uplifter
community and I'd like to thank my
community for helping me tell this story
I'd like to thank my mom and my stepdad
who are here for supporting me
spiritually morally and sometimes
financially I'd like to think that yes
like to thank my dad sherrod banks
window/tab at Hillside high school in
Durham North Carolina
Casey lemon Spike Lee Casey went through
18 drafts of my script with me and gave
me countless support I'd like to thank
Alex Rockwell Barbra shot Bob Nixon
Peggy Rice key and all the faculty and
staff at NYU's Graduate film program I'd
like to thank all of my NYU classmates
but especially Sasha Nisha Myers link
you are young in a V Rockwell Jordan lon
are Peter Dada you ta the amazing Nina
Shaw Robby casick as mad at cast
management Jasmine guy Todd Harris Jake
Berlin at metro graph dr. Tina Smith my
brother Austin James who's been with me
on this journey from the beginning
producer Tanisha Fordham Lauren Lauren
Owen Ethan Lee Burton time Larry
Isabella Oliveira and my cinematographer
Laura balladeer who I think is the best
cinematographer in the world meet her
after this is over please meet her shake
her hand and have her shoot your next
film I'd like to thank Keith Beauchamp
Adam Perry Tyree Webb Lauren Ebanks the
entire cast and crew of my nephew Emmitt
my productors honor mark Terry and
everyone who worked on this project most
people work for next to nothing and I'd
like to say thank you to the Academy for
recognizing the enduring relevance of
image sales legacy and for giving me a
platform to continue telling this story
and finally these days it feels like
we're living in an extremely trying time
and I personally have experienced the
most of Isis goodness that I've
experienced in my lifetime but I am
encouraged because there's so much love
to give
I'm looking forward to continue to use
cinema as a tool to spread that love to
spread hope and to spread healing I
thank God and I thank you god bless you
all thank you
[Applause]